ALL RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN
WE WELCOME YOU TO THE SEPTEMBER
EDITION OF THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE IT'S GOING TO BE
COMING TO ORDER. WE HAVE ONE
BILL ON THE DOCKET TODAY THAT'S
AB FIVE HUNDRED IS A MEMBER
WARD FOR ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT- OUR PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER TODAY IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE THREE WITH THE CODE.
SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX NINE OH
NINE THAT TOLL FREE NUMBER IS
CURRENTLY ON YOUR SCREEN WE
WELCOME. ANY AND ALL
PARTICIPATION IN RESPONSE TO
THE KOBE NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AS WELL AS THE AMAZING STAFF
HERE. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN AD
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THE SENATE
IS MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS
TO NORMAL PRACTICES. IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AGAIN WE
WELCOME YOUR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. EITHER HERE
TODAY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE OR VIA OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE ONE MORE TIME. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE THREE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR IF YOU ARE CALLING
AND WE SO APPRECIATE THE GOOD
WORK BY MR MODERATOR. YOU'RE
THEN GOING TO DIAL ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. THAT WE
ASK IF YOU DON'T MIND TO PLEASE
MOVE MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING- WHILE YOU'RE GIVING
TESTIMONY SOMETIMES WE GET A
SOME FEEDBACK THAT SOUNDS. LIKE
A BANSHEE SCREAMING IN THE YEAR
SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
PLEASE MUTE YOUR DEVICE WHILE
YOU'RE SPEAKING TO COMMITTEES.
IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL BECOMES UNRULY.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THAT
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE AT
TO BE A REMOVE THEMSELVES IF
THEY DON'T DO THAT THAT YOU
WILL BE REMOVED. FROM THE
REMOTE MEETING SERVICE ARE
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OF
THREE. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN
ONCE AGAIN NOW WE HAVE ONE ITEM
ON TODAY'S DOCKET. AND THAT IS
AS THE MEMBER WARDS AB FIVE
HUNDRED. SUMMER WARD I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANKS FOR
WORKING WITH COMMITTEE THAT
WERE REALLY GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF
YOUR PARTNERSHIP HERE- AND-
SOME REWARD HAS REALLY BEEN
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT CAN
WORK. IN FOCUSING ON
DESPERATELY NEEDED HOUSING- IN
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT AS A
MEMBER MORE. THAT YOU WANT TO
ADDRESS THE INTER BETWEEN THE
SUPPORT OF HOUSING PROJECTS
THAT WOULD BE STREAMLINED UNDER
THIS BILL IN THE STATE'S EFFORT
ON HOME KEY I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE A FULL. PIECE OF TESTIMONY
BACK TO BE ABLE TO FILL HERE
TODAY BUT ON THAT ISSUE OF THE
STATE'S EFFORTS ON HOME KEEN
STREAMLINING I THINK THAT'S AN
AREA THAT YOU WANT TO FOCUS ON
FOR POTENTIAL CLEAN UP. BEFORE
YOU GET INTO THAT- IF YOU DON'T
MIND I WANT TO CONFIRM THAT IS
NOT THE CASE THANK YOU RESEARCH
AREA ABSOLUTELY A LONG TIME
SUPPORTER OF MANY OF THE
EXISTING STATUTORY LABOR
PROVISIONS THAT APPLY TO HIM HE
PROJECTS AND CERTAINLY WOULD
BE. HAPPY TO COMMIT TO WORKING
ON SOME FORM OF LEGISLATION
WHETHER IT'S FOR MY OWN. FUTURE
WORK OR SOMEBODY ELSE'S VEHICLE
ABOUT THE VEHICLE AND THEN MAKE
SURE THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
CLARIFIED FOR AGAIN THE VERY
SAME- TYPES OF PROJECTS THAT
ARE ALREADY EXISTING UNDER
PROJECT ON P. THAT'S GREAT SO
WHATEVER IS EXISTING THE
STATUTORY LABOR PROVISIONS.
THAT APPLY TO HUNKY PROJECTS
NOW THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE GONNA
BE LOOKING AT CLEAN UP EITHER
THROUGH YOUR OWN
PERSONALIZATION POTENTIALLY
THROUGH THE BUDGET. IN JANUARY
SIR AND WITH YOU YES THANK YOU
SO MUCH A 100% AND- ABSOLUTELY
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU.
AS A MORE WORK ON THIS AND
AGAIN DECEMBER WARD THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH COMMITTEE- A
LONG WAYS TO CLOSE THE
COMMISSION OVER THESE PAST MANY
MONTHS WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE SIR. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THAN YOU CENTER AND I
THINK IT'S A REALLY GREAT PLACE
TO START BECAUSE THIS BILL AB
FIVE HUNDRED IS ABOUT
CONSISTENCY IS ABOUT TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT SOME OF THE
HOUSING PRODUCTION THAT WE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO SEE IN MANY OF
OUR WONDERFUL. RESIDENTIAL
ZONES ARE ACTUALLY STREAMLINED
AND AFFORDED NOT JUST FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WHICH WE'VE
ALREADY OUT- ASCERTAIN THROUGH
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION. ALSO
THROUGH THE COASTAL DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS A SEPARATE PROCESS THAT
IS REGULATED BY THE STATE. WE
KNOW THE CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO EXPERIENCE A HUGE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS WITH THE
DEFICIENCY OF THREE MILLION.
HOMES AND GROWING IT'S
EXACERBATED IN SOME OF THESE
PRESIDENTIAL ISSUES IN THE
COASTAL ZONE WHERE DEVELOPMENTS
FACED A NUMBER OF VERY SPECIFIC
AREAS CHALLENGES. EDUS
SUPPORTABLE HOUSE SUPPORTED
HOUSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING CAN
PROVIDE SOLUTIONS TO. HELP.
ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS FOR
MIDDLE AND LOW INCOME CAL. YEAH
THEY ARE UNDER YOU'D- IN THE
COAST ZONE BECAUSE- OF THE-
INTO. BUT NECESSARY. PERSONAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT. AND AS I
MENTIONED WE'VE IN RECENT YEARS
PASS LAWS TO STREAMLINE THAT.
FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS BUT HE
DID NOT EXTEND TO SEE PEACE SO
THAT'S WHERE AB FIVE HUNDRED
COMES IN AND CONNECTS THESE
DOTS. IT WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO AMANDA LOCAL
POSTAL PROGRAMS BY JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. TO
IDENTIFY THE CIRCUMSTANCES IN
LOCATIONS ON THE WEST EIGHTY
USE TRINITY USE. LOW BARRIER
NAVIGATION CENTERS. SUPPORTED
HOUSING PROJECTS AND 1100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WOULD BE
EXEMPT OR QUALIFY FOR. A WAIVER
FOR THE COASTAL DEVELOPMENT
PERMIT. APPROVING THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE DEVELOPERS A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
REGULATIONS AND TIMELINES FOR
LOW IMPACT HOUSING PROJECTS IN
THE COASTAL ZONE. AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR WORKING
SO CLOSELY WITH ME ON THE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE BILL THAT
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO DO
SO OVER THE SUMMER RECESS. I
WANT TO THANK ANTON IN THE REST
OF YOUR STOP AS WELL. ON FOR
THEIR- EXPERTISE AND GUIDANCE
THROUGHOUT THIS SPECIAL
PROCESS. AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST- I DON'T. THANK YOU SO
MUCH ASSEMBLY REWARDED VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE
ONE INDIVIDUAL WILL BE OUR LEAD
WITNESS. IN SUPPORT OF IT
THAT'S GONNA BE SERRA CHRISTIE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION. WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
TODAY AS FAR AS- ARE RUN A
SHOW. WILL FIRST HEAR FROM OUR
LEAD WITNESS OR THE INTERNET
CHECKING WITH ANYONE WHO'D LIKE
TO BE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL HERE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE. THEN WE'RE GONNA GO TO
THE PHONE LINES IN SUPPORT.
THEN WE HAVE TO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES FIRST AND FOREMOST
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM ERIN
LEHANE REPRESENTING. AT THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM SHARON
GONZALEZ. FROM THE CITY OF
CARLSBAD. SO LET'S GET INTO IT
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THAT WE
ARE GOING TO WELCOME THE
NECESSARY CHRISTY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA. COASTAL COMMISSION
MISS CHRISTY YOU HAVE. THREE
MINUTES WE WELCOME YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK
ON PROTECTING. THE COAST MISS
CHRISTY THE FLOOR IS YOURS. ALL
RIGHT THIS IS SMOOTH AS SILK
LADIES IN GERMAN WE WELCOME
YOU. TO THE SMOOTH THE CELL
CARING- AND WE'RE GOING TO. DO
YOU GOT I MISS CHRISTY MISS
CHRISTY IS OUT. OF PROTECTING
THE COAST EVEN AS WE SPEAK
RIGHT NOW. SO WE'RE GONNA COME
BACK TO MISS CHRISTY. AND I
CHECK IN WITH HER IN JUST A
MOMENT. SO WE'RE NOW GOING TO
CHECK IN TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF
THE BILL HERE IN OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM AND I GOTTA TELL YOU WE'VE
HAD TO PUSH PEOPLE BACK. OUT OF
THE OVERFLOW ROOM HERE TODAY.
NOTHING'S HAPPENING THE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SO I LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TO
THE PHONE LINES WERE CHECKING
IN WITH OUR TOLL FREE PHONE
LINES. AGAIN WE WELCOME YOUR
PARTICIPATION HERE TODAY. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE THREE. LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINES RESTAURANT
MODERATOR AND THAT'S WELCOME
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
HUNDRED MISTER MODERATOR. OF
COURSE LAYS IN GERMAN. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. OUR FIRST
SUPPORT IS FROM THE LINE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
TWENTY ONE YEAR AND COMMITTEE
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY HEAR ME
YES YOU'RE COMING IN LOUD AND
CLEAR WE WELCOME YOU HERE IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED ALONG
THE LINE BUT- MY NAME IS- CHRIS
THERE WITH THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS I DANCE FOR THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSING
THIS UNTIL UNLESS IT'S- AND-
AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH I MISTER CENTER CALLING
FOR CINEMA COUNTY HERE TODAY WE
WELCOME MISTER SNYDER- AND
AGAIN. WE TAKE EVERYONE WHETHER
IT'S- OPPOSITION DURING SUPPORT
OR SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION
IT'S ALL GOOD WERE INTO SESSION
ANYTHING'S GOING TO HAPPEN HERE
SO LET'S KEEP GOING WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. FIVE HUNDRED
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE MR MODERATOR. OF COURSE
OUR NEXT ONE COMES ON THE LINE
AT TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME SECOND YES
YOU'RE LOUD AND CLEAR YOUR IN
COMMITTEE NOW MA'AM PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU I'M SORRY
I'M I'M ACTUALLY IN OPPOSITION
AS WELL MY NAME IS CAROL
CANNONS AND I'M FROM THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION I GET A MUCH
AMENDED- ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING
TRADES REQUESTS. FOR BUILDING
TRAINED WORKFORCE AND
PREVAILING WAGE- ON ALL
AFFORDABLE AND SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH HIS CAMPAIGN SHEER PHONE
CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. OUR NEXT ONE
COMES FROM THE LINE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT MANY OF
THEM WAS ONE THAT- SAN DIEGO
IRONWORKERS LOCAL TO TONIGHT WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION A LOT ABOUT
THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL-
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. EXCELLENT FROM LINE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. YES GOOD EVENING
GOOD AFTERNOON MA'AM YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED.
AUDREY RETIRED CHECK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOU TERM
ACQUIRE AND- YOUR CONSULTANT
AND AUTHOR COMING ON BOARD
AFTER WORKING ON THAT BILL WITH
THAT- WE'RE VERY THANKFUL FOR
THE LETTER TO THE JOURNAL THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF THE MEETING
AND WITH THAT WE'RE REMOVING
OUR OPPOSITION BUT WE JUST
WANTED TO MAKE THAT KNOWN TODAY
THANK YOU GUYS FOR ALL THE HARD
WORK. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
APPRECIATE THAT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE'RE GOING TO HIT
THE PAUSE BUTTON HERE
MOMENTARILY IN OUR AYE
TELECONFERENCE LINE BECAUSE WE
EVER LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS WHO'S
NOW ON THE LINE THIS IS SERRA
CHRISTIE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION MISS CHRISTY
GOOD AFTERNOON WE WELCOME YOU
TO COMMITTEE. YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES PLEASE PROCEED. I'M
GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRY. I'M SURE
CHRISTY WITH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WHICH IS ANOTHER
VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO SUPPORT
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED. ALTHOUGH
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL HAS BEEN
NARROWED SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE
YOU FIRST FOUGHT IT. THE
VERSION THAT'S BEFORE YOU-
STILL HAS- THE COASTAL
COMMISSION'S. STRONG SUPPORT-
UPDATING LOCAL COUNCIL PROGRAMS
TO HARMONIZE THE EVOLVING
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS FOR
HOUSING WITH LONG ESTABLISHED
COAST LIKE POLICIES. WILL HELP
VERIFY THE STREAMLINED PROCESS
FOR DEVELOPING HOUSING TYPE
SPECIFIED IN THE BILL. WHICH
WILL BENEFIT APPLICANTS LOCAL.
COMMISSION'S PREVIOUS GUIDANCE
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND DOES
NOT GIVE THE COMMISSION ADDING
LOOK ALREADY. BUT IT DOES PUT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ON THE PAST
BUT NOT YET DONE SO TO AMEND
THEIR LTTE'S. ABOUT TWO THIRDS
OF THE SIXTY FOUR CERTIFIED
JURISDICTIONS HAVE ALREADY
VOLUNTARILY AMENDED THERE'LL BE
PEACE TO ADDRESS EIGHTY YOU AND
J. EIGHTY YOU. ARE ARE WELL
DOWN THE PATH TO DOING SO. AS
AMENDED AB FIVE HUNDRED WILL
REQUIRE THE INCLUSION OF
EXPEDITED PROCESSING OF A 100%
AFFORDABLE UNITS. TRANSITIONAL
SUPPORT HOUSING. AND LOW
BARRIER NAVIGATION CENTERS. AND
WHILE AMENDING ALL SIXTY FOUR
LCTS IN A TWO YEAR TIME FRAME
IS AMBITIOUS. THE COMMISSION
BELIEVES IT CAN ACCOMPLISH THE
TASK WITH A MODEST INCREASE IN
LIMITED TERMS STAFF. WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WARD AND HIS STAFF FOR THEIR
DILIGENCE COMMITMENT TO THIS
ISSUE. AS WELL AS COMMITTEE
STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS WHO
WORKED OVER THE INTERIM TO
CRAFT THIS CONSENSUS SOLUTION
I'M HAPPY TO REMAIN ON THE LINE
FOR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL- FOR
THE TESTIMONY I MISS CHRISTY.
ALRIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE
ARE NOW GOING TO GO BACK TO OUR
PHONE LINES WE ARE CURRENTLY IN
THE SUPPORT CATEGORY LET'S
CHECK IN- HERE MISTER MODERATOR
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. IN SUPPORT
WE MAY ALSO HAVE SOME IN
OPPOSITION BUT LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OF COURSE
OUR NEXT CALLER IS FROM LINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
STAGGERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR PHONE
CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BACK
FROM THE FROM LINE AT TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE
MEMBERS- JAMES DIRECTOR OF THE
KENTUCKY STATE COUNCIL LABORERS
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THEY'RE CURRENTLY KNOW THE
COLLEGE QUEUED UP AND AS A
REMINDER IF HE DID WISH TO OR
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF IT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THIS IS GONNA BE LAST CALL LAST
CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT LAST CALL FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE DIAL ONE EIGHT
ZERO. LAST CALL FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE HUNDRED ONE
THEN ZERO PLEASE PRESS OUT ON
YOUR- TOUCH TONE PAD NOW.
MISTER MODERATOR LET'S CHECK IN
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
INDIVIDUALS. FOR SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE HUNDRED. IT IS STILL
CURRENTLY NO ONE THAT HAS
QUEUED UP THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR ALRIGHT LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN NOW TO BE GOING
TO THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION-
WE ARE GOING TO START WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL.
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL ARE CURRENTLY IN
COMMITTEE THAT WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE I MISS THE HANGING AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO BE HAVING-
THE PRESIDENT ELECT HE'S GONNA
BE JOINING US AS WELL WHICH-
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR. MISTER HAN
THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES BETWEEN
YOURSELF AND I MISTER PRESIDENT
PLEASE. HEY THERE YOU GO
EXACTLY- I JUST WANTED BEFORE
MISS LANE GET STARTED WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GET THE CLOCK IS
MISTER HAYNES MIKE ON. NOW THIS
LANE SPOKE TOO SOON. B. AND G.
NOISE FOR THE AREA THANK YOU
HEAR ME NOW YES OKAY I'M SORRY
ABOUT THAT IN SENATOR MCGUIRE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE-
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ERIN
LEHANE APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE HALF A MILLION
MEMBERS OF THE STATE BUILT
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. IN
LESS FAIR LABOR STANDARDS ARE
ADDED TO ALL SUPPORT OF AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- THAT WILL
BE STREAMLINED BY THIS BILL. AS
ALL OF YOU ON THIS COMMITTEE
KNOWS THE BUILDING TRADES HAVE
BEEN ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
ATTEMPTING TO MOVE HOUSING
BILLS THIS SESSION. CALIFORNIA
HAS AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS BUT IT ALSO HAS A LABOR
CRISIS IN RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION. AS A RECENT UC
BERKELEY STUDY POINTED OUT THE
NEARLY THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE FAMILY PROGRAMS A YEAR
GOES TO SUPPORT THE FAMILIES OF
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS. WHO ARE NOT PAID
ENOUGH TO SUPPORT THE BASIC
NEEDS OF THEIR FAMILIES. THIS
IS UNACCEPTABLE AND IT SHOULD
BE UNACCEPTABLE TO EVERY SINGLE
ELECTED OFFICIAL IN THE STATE.
WE HAVE STOOD BY IN THE PAST TO
STREAMLINING BILLS WERE PASSED
WITH PROMISES OF HIGH ROAD
LABOR PRACTICES AND WHAT WE SAW
IS AN EMBOLDENING OF THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY WHERE
WORKERS RISK THEIR LIVES. WORK
IN BLAZING HEAT LIKE TODAY AND
ARE NOT GIVEN THE RESPECT OF
EVEN A FAIR WAGE. WE HAVE
SPOKEN TO WORKERS ALL OVER THE
STATE I'M PROJECTS SUPPORTED BY
LEGISLATIVE STREAMLINING AND
THE TAXPAYERS THAT
SYSTEMATICALLY CHEAP WORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. WE SHOULD
BE BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUT IT SHOULD NOT BE DONE OVER
THE BACKS OF CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS. CALIFORNIA CAN AND
SHOULD DO BETTER THAN THAT. AND
I WOULD SEE THE REST OF MY TIME
PROBABLY TO THE PRESIDENT ELECT
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ANDREW MEREDITH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT LIKE WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE SIR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND YOU HAVE
ABOUT A MINUTE LEFT SIR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS WE WELCOME YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WANT
TO SEE A SPECIAL HELLO TO MY
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVE IN THE
STATE SENATE SENATOR JIM
NIELSEN. WHO I'VE KNOWN FOR
QUITE A LONG TIME. I WANT TO
EXPLAIN FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
WHY THESE ISSUES ARE SO
IMPORTANT TO US AS AN
ORGANIZATION STATEWIDE SEQUEL
EXEMPTIONS WITHOUT STRINGENT
LABOR PROTECTIONS. ROB WORKING
CLASS PEOPLE OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR JOBS NOW I'M A VETERAN OF
THE IRAQ WAR LIKE MANY EMBERS
OF OUR ORGANIZATION I CAME
THROUGH THE MILITARY. GOT INTO
OUR ORGANIZATION FOR A CHANCE
OF THE MIDDLE CLASS JOBS. HAVE
ALSO BEEN AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
BEFORE SO I KNOW THE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS THAT HAVE TO BE. IN
REGARDS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WHAT I THINK YOU NEED TO KEEP
IN PERSPECTIVE IS THIS WE ARE A
BARRIER FREE MIDDLE CLASS ALSO.
WITH CARE WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL
COMES FROM WE DON'T CARE WHAT
THEIR RACE OR GENDER OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AS- WE ARE BARRIER
FREE. WITHOUT ORGANIZATIONS
WITH OPPORTUNITIES LIKE US THE
MIDDLE CLASS WOULD LOOK
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT. WE
URGE THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL.
TO MAKE THE CHANGES THAT WE'VE
REQUESTED. AND WE URGE A NO
VOTE. TO PREVENT THIS FROM
GETTING OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
TODAY THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
WITH US WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
OUR- NEXT. PRESENTER PLEASE I
FOR THE FIRST AND LAST NAME AS
WELL AS A SOLUTION PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MIKE
WEST ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES AND OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH JUST WEST
COULD SEE SIR. SEMI FINAL CALL
FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION
AB FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
OR THREE FINAL CALL PLEASE.
PORTANTINO WHEN WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE GONE FOR OVER FOUR ROOM ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE- CENTER
DRIVE SO ANYBODY IN FORTY TWO
OVER HERE TODAY- JUST CRICKETS.
IT'S PRETTY BAD NINE I KNOW
IT'S IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
AT PER CENTER DRAWS OR NOT AND
WE GOING TOWARD TOLL FREE PHONE
LINES IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE THREE WE'RE
TAKING OPPOSITION TESTIMONY NOW
IN AB FIVE HUNDRED. MISTER
MODERATOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR OPPOSITION AB FIVE HUNDRED.
RIGHT ENGINE ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FIVE HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. OUR FIRST ONE
COMES FROM THE LINE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TOM LANDON CALLING
OUT OF SAN DIEGO- THE BIG SHOUT
OUT TO. SENATOR MCGUIRE YOUR
ENERGY IS JUST STOCKLEY
KIDDING- I'M CALLING ACTUALLY
ON TWO ORGANIZATIONS- WATERS
THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
ORGANIZATION THAT IS OWNED AND
OPERATED BY THE SAN DIEGO
BUILDING TRADES- WHERE I
ACTUALLY GREW UP AND HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS THE CEO
TODAY AS WELL AS THE SAN DIEGO
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES THE REPRESENTS. THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND UNION
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS- IN
OPPOSITION- AND IT'S A SHAME
THAT- WE SCHEMES AFTER THE PLAY
THE SAME GAME- WOOD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARDS BILLS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
NEXT CALLER HERE IN OPPOSITION
POLICE- MISTER MODERATOR. NEXT
ONE IS FROM THE LINE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE TERM
REQUIRES KEEP DON'T THE
DISTRICT COUNCIL OF IRON
WORKERS STANDING WITH THE STATE
CONSTRUCTION BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FASTER THAN- MY MISTAKE LAYS IN
GERMAN WE HAD A SECOND LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS I APOLOGIZE
IN ENSURING GONZALEZ- CITY
CARLSBAD I'M GONNA LOOK TO
COMMITTEE IF IT'S ALL RIGHT AND
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO BRING THIS
BECAUSE ALL SUB- AND APOLOGIZE
TO HER. GONZALEZ I AM SO SORRY
THAT IS COMPLETELY MY FAULT IN
REGARDS TO RIGHT NOT ADVANCE IN
YOU AFTER- MISS THE HAIN SO
WE'RE GONNA ALLOW FOR MISS
GONZALEZ TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF CARLSBAD
AND WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO OUR-
ON PHONE TESTIMONY I SHARON
GOOD AFTERNOON WE WELCOME YOU
TO COMMITTEE. FROM THE CITY OF
CARLSBAD. RIGHT THANK YOU
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH. YOUR COMMENT SHARING
INVOLVED IS A GREAT PUBLIC
POLICY GROUP. AGAIN TESTIFYING
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
CARLSBAD. WE APPRECIATE WITH
YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS TRYING TO
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO INCREASE
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND COASTAL
DOWN HOWEVER WE MEASURE. ACT AB%
OUR PRIMARY. AND DRAFTED THE
TIME WHEN HE- THE NEARLY HOUR
LOCAL AGENCIES L. A. DOT AN
AMENDMENT YOU ARE LOCAL. PLAN
IDENTIFY WHAT YOU INCREASE
ACROSS EIGHTEEN CAN AFFORDABLE
HOW AND- RAMOS CIRCUMSTANCE.
NEED TO BE CAN R. AS THE
PLANNING THE TRY AND CAN- THE
TRACK OF THE COMMUNITY AND OF
TALKING. AND LOCAL AGENTS ARE
REQUIRED PROVIDE INSURANCE.
ACQUIRED INCOME IN THE SHARE
TIME THAT WE ANYONE CANNOT THE
L. AND ACTUALLY THAT A WOULD
TAKE YOU FROM TWENTY FOUR YOU
MIND CHOI DOC AND THEN THE TO
THE OF P. JERRY STEP. AT A
LOCAL HE NEEDS TO TAKE HER DOWN
JIM. WOULD REQUIRE. SIXTY
MONTHS OF OUT FOR AND ABOUT.
ALL OF IN ADDITION TWELVE TO
EIGHTEEN BEFORE REPEAL
DEPENDING THE LEVEL OF IMPACT
THAT INCLUDES THIRTY OR FORTY
FIVE DAY PUBLIC REVIEW PERIOD.
RESPOND TO COMMENTS AND ANY
PREPARATION OF FINDING TWENTY
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS.
UNERRING LATER PROBABLY TAKEN
ONE TO THREE MONTHS THE
PLANNING COMMISSION REVIEW.
ANOTHER ONE TO THREE MONTHS FOR
CITY COUNCIL REVIEW AND THEN
ANYWHERE FROM TWO TO FOURTEEN
ONE OR CULTURAL COMMISSION
RUBIO. HI MY DOESN'T EVEN TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION ANY
ADDITIONAL TIME THAT MIGHT BE
NECESSARY TO WORK ON TOP. FROM
THE COMMUNITY OR TRIED ANY
ISSUES THAT ARISE DURING YOU
PROCESS. FOR CITY COUNCIL
ACTION ON PROPOSED
MODIFICATIONS FROM THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. ACTUALLY IN THE
ANALYSIS LAW ESTABLISHES
PERMITTING. FOR SEVERAL OF
HOUSING BECAUSE INCLUDING
EIGHTY YEARS JUNIOR EIGHTY YEAR
AREN'T QUITE HOUSING AND LOCAL
NAVIGATION. A FOR HOUSING
WILLIAM FROM COASTAL IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY AND ARE. PEOPLE
IN THE CAR ACT BUT THE ALL DUE
TO PROMOTE A FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPER. WITH ALL THIS
CONSIDERED. AMENDED OUR OLD
PEACH I. STREAMLINED PROVISION
CRAIG AFFORDABLE BY JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IST
SIMPLY NERGY LOCAL EXPERTISE
RESULT. OF FANTASTIC HELD
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
RIGHT GRATEFUL. THIS IS EVER
GONNA GO BACK TO TOLL FREE TOLL
FOR LINE HERE IN CHECK IN WITH
OUR NEXT- INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB
FIVE HUNDRED MISTER MODERATOR
THAT'S PROCEED WITH THOSE. ON
THE PHONE LINE. OF COURSE OUR
NECKS AND COMES FROM A LINE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU ARE SENATOR MCGUIRE
THIS IS NOT A JOB HUNTER LOG.
FROM THE OPERATING ENGINEERS
ALSO- BUMBLE DELMARK BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES WE
STAND IN OPPOSITION WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER ARNOLD COMECON
IN THE GREAT NORTH COAST IT'S
GOING TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
OUR NEXT CALLER COMES FROM LINE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THIRTY TWO YEAR AND
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
HELLO THIS IS MARGARET REPAIR
KNOWLEDGE RIGHT WE'LL SEE HOW
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
OPPOSITION WAS DENIED. MIKE
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THE COLOURS
LINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BOB CHAIRMAN OF MEMBERS-
JIM GRAHAM AND INTERNATIONAL
OPERATING ENGINEERS I THINK
WE'RE JUST HAPPY HERE IS
CONSISTENT THING WITH LONG HELD
POLICY THAT APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS. IF THEY PROJECT
PROCEEDING UNIQUE PUBLIC
BENEFITTED SHOULD ABIDE BY
BASICALLY LABOR STANDARDS ARE
ASKING FOR OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THAT THANK. YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND PATIENCE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS CURRENT
COLOR PLAY. THANKS CALLRS FROM
LINE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS MITCHELL
BECHTEL WITH THE IRON WORKERS
LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN WE STAND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION ALYSSA MENDEZ.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SPECTRUM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THEY'RE
CURRENTLY NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE BUT AS A REMINDER IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. LAST CALL LAST
CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION AB FIVE HUNDRED
PLEASE DIAL ONE AND ZERO LAST
CALL FOR OPPOSITION DOW ONE
THEN ZERO. THE MODERATOR THAT'S
TO A LAST CALL ON THE LINE
PLEASE. CURRENTLY NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE STILL THIS MATTER THANKS
FOR ALL YOUR WORK TODAY AGAIN
LAYS IN GENERAL COMMITTEE THIS
IS OUR ONE AND ONLY BILL WOULD
LIKE TODAY TO SEE IF THERE ARE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE. HERE
TODAY PLEASE CENTER DRAWS OF
FORESTERS. YES IF THE AUTHOR
COULD SPEAK TO THE LABOR
ISSUES. THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
ON- SORT OF AT A LOSS HERE.
THANK YOU SENATOR OF HAVING TO
I'M AT A LOSS AS WELL- DESPITE
I THINK FIRST DISCUSSING THIS
BLL WITH US SOME OF THE- NOW
OPPONENTS AS EARLY AS MARCH OF
THIS YEAR. IT WASN'T UNTIL
ABOUT NINETY MINUTES AGO THAT I
RECEIVED ANY COMMUNICATION
THERE WAS ANYTHING SPECIFIC
WITH THIS BILL UP AS I SAID MY
OPENING STATEMENT I AM
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON. MAKING SURE THE CONSISTENCY
THERE FOR EXISTING STATUTORY
LABOR PROTECTIONS WHICH I
SUPPORT. FOR MANY OF THE SAME
PROJECTS IS REFLECTED IN
CONSISTENT WITH THE BILL HERE.
SAID THIS BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND BE SIGNED INTO LAW
THE IMPORTANT POINT HERE IS
THAT ANYTHING YOU KNOW WELL YOU
SERVED ON THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. BEFORE AS WELL THIS
IS A SPECIAL BUT ADDITIVE LAYER
OF REVIEW THAT WE HAVE ABOVE
EVEN LOCAL JURISDICTION
ADOPTION MANY OF THESE-
STREAMLINING OR OTHER
CONDITIONS THAT WE ARE
DISCUSSING ON SOME OF THESE
POTENTIAL PROJECTS. HAVE BEEN
AFFORDED HER HAVE HAD THAT
DISCUSSION AT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION LEVEL AND SO WE'RE
WE'RE HAVING THE SKILLED AND
TRAINED LANGUAGE PREVAILING
WAGE AND OTHER. LABOUR
PROVISIONS APPLIED ARE LIKELY
ALREADY REFLECTED IN THE
UNDERLYING PROJECT WHICH WAS
POSSIBLY APPROVED BY A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. THIS IS MAKES FOR
THE PURPOSES OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION'S REVIEW. THAT THAT-
AS WE LOOK FOR THE PROTECTION
OF NATURAL RESOURCES AS WE LOOK
TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE ARE.
AFFORDING ADDITIONAL. A
PORTABLE HOUSING. OPPORTUNITIES
FOR WORK FOR ARE FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA. THAT CLOSE OF A
VIOLENT CRIME PROCESS IS ALSO
STREAMLINED. WELL SO. IS THIS I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WAS THIS- JUST
A CHANGE DID YOU HAVE DID YOUR
RECENT AMENDMENTS HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO WITH. THE LABOR ISSUES
ANY BUILDING YOU SEE BEFORE
YOU- WAS NOT SUBSTANTIALLY
CHANGE FROM THE PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION IN COMMITTEE- WHAT
WAS REMOVED WAS THE MORE
EXPENSIVE CONVERSATION AROUND
THE COASTAL COMMISSION'S
AUTHORITY AROUND HOUSING
POLICIES IN THE LOCAL COASTAL
PLANS. MAY I HAVE. YOUR PLEASE
THEY SHOULD HAVE THEY COULD
RESPOND TO THAT. I MEAN WE DO
WE TYPICALLY DON'T DO THAT NOW
THAT WE'VE CLOSED PUBLIC
TESTIMONY OKAY I'M JUST TRYING
TO. GET A OF FEEL HERE I MEAN
THIS WAS. THIS IS MOVING
FORWARD BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT.
THERE'S ALL THIS OPPOSITION
FROM FROM THE BUILDING TRADES
AND ARE WE GOING TO FIX THIS.
BECAUSE OF YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE
WILLING TO OR YOU'RE COMMITTED
TO THE BUILDING TRADE LABOR
STANDARDS THAN. HOW DO WE GET
THERE AT THIS POINT IN TIME I
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
COULD SOMEBODY MAYBE THAT
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS SOMEBODY
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. WHAT WHAT
I CAN SAY IS I THINK ON THE
ISSUE AND I DON'T EVER WANT TO
SPEAK. FOR ANY ORGANIZATION I
THINK THAT THERE IS CONCERN IN
REGARDS TO STREAMLINING WHETHER
IT'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
ON THE ISSUE- PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WHERE AND I
WANT TO WORDS IN THE SOME
MEMBERS MATH- WHERE THESE TO
MEMBER IS COMMITTED TO BE ABLE
TO FIX- ON ANY PROJECT HOME KEY
DEVELOPMENT. THAT IS IT VANCE.
UNDER THIS BILL THERE IS GOING
TO HAVE TO BE CLEAN UP NEXT
YEAR TO ENSURE THAT- THE LABOR
PROVISIONS. THAT ARE ALREADY IN
STATE STATUTE NOW. VIA SKILLED
AND TRAINED THAT WOULD BE
ADVANCED WITH THIS BILL SO FOR
EXAMPLE- IF. UNDER PROJECT
COUNTY RIGHT NOW. IF A SEQUEL
EXEMPTION IS GRANTED FOR NEW
DEVELOPMENT- OR REMODELING
REHAB. THEN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. CAN EXCEED CAN
RECEIVE THAT- SECRET TENSION
BUT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
BUILD SKILLED AND TRAINED- AND
THAT IS WHAT THE REFLECTION
WILL BE. IS ENSURING THAT THIS
BILL IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
CURRENT STATUTORY LANGUAGE
THAT'S IN LINE NOW. IT WOULD
NOT APPLY 2100% AFFORDABLE SO
RIGHT NOW THIS BILL- REQUEST
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT BY JULY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. SUBMIT AND
THE LOCAL COASTAL PLAN
AMENDMENT- TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS OF DEVELOPMENTS- OF
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS
NAVIGATION CENTERS 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ALONG WITH
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING-
ON THE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING PIECE WITH HUNKY. THOSE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFYING THAT
HUNKY STILL MUST BE BUILT
SKILLED TRAINERS BECAUSE
EMISSIONS WOULD BE CLEANED UP-
THIS COMING YEAR AS FAR AS A
100% AFFORDABLE HI THERE WOULD
NOT BE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE ON
THAT IN THIS BILL THE OTHER
SIGNIFICAN AMENDMENT THAT HAS
BEEN TAKEN IN PLEASES A MEMBER
WARD PUSHED BACK TO ME THINK
I'M- MISTAKEN. IS ON HAZARDOUS
AREAS SO- CENTER WIENER ON THE
OF HOUSING CENTER STERN A
BEHALF NOT TO RESOURCES IN THIS
COMMITTEE HAVE ALL BEEN MEETING
TO TRY TO BE ABLE TO GET
CONSENSUS. ON AND ON THAT ISSUE
ON IT IF THERE IS A HAZARDOUS
FIRE ZONE. AND THE COMMUNITY I
CAN'T MITIGATE FOR THOSE.
HAZARDOUS FIRE CONDITIONS DANA
DEVELOPMENT WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
STOPPED SO THAT'S ALL I'M
PARAPHRASING HERE THAT IS ALSO
IN THIS BILL IS WELL THE LAST
PIECE OF SAY IS THIS BILL THAT
WAS PREVIOUSLY IN FRONT OF US
WAS MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE AND
THIS BILL NOW IS MUCH MORE
STRATEGIC FOCUSING ON- THOSE
AFFORDABLE. HOUSING STOCK OR
NIGHT NAVIGATION CENTERS THAT
CAN GET DEPLOYED- AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BUT SOME REWARD I
DON'T WANT TO EVER PUT WORDS IN
YOUR MOUTH YOU KNOW TURN OVER
THE MAJORITY LEADER RIGHT AFTER
SENATOR ALSO MAY BE DONE BUT-
THIS SUMMER WARD I DON'T WORDS
IN YOUR MOUTH I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT'S ACCURATE ABOUT WHICH IS
A 100% ACCURATE I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING THE ONLY THING I
WOULD ADD AGAIN TO SORT OF
SIMPLIFY THIS IS IT IF YOU HAVE
THE PROJECT IS MOVING FORWARD
AND I APPRECIATE THE SENATE'S
PREVIOUS WORK ON. PROJECT HOME
CAN'T ALIGN THAT WITH SOME OF
OUR LABOR STANDARDS AND IF YOU
HAVE THAT PROJECT THIS MOVE FOR
THAT'S BEEN ADOPTED BY THE
LOCAL JURISDICTION YOU WILL
HAVE THOSE REQUIREMENTS ALREADY
IN PLACE BECAUSE THAT IS A
PROVISION REQUIRED TO BE ABLE
TO EVEN MOVE FORWARD TO RECEIVE
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
APPROVAL SO NOW YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE TO THEN TAKE A
PROTOTYPICAL SO YOU DON'T HAVE
A PROJECT FROM STREET TO THE
COASTAL COMMISSION YOU STILL
NEED UNDERLYING LOCAL
JURISDICTION REVIEW AND
APPROVAL BEFORE THEN. THE
COUNCIL COMMISSIONER UNDER ITS
PURVIEW SO I WOULD BE
COMFORTABLE KNOWING THAT MANY
OF THESE PROJECTS THAT WOULD
ALIGN WITH THE SENATE'S
PREVIOUS WORK ARE GOING TO BE
CAPTURED HERE AND IF IT HELPS
THE OPPOSITION BECOME ALSO
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT I
CERTAINLY HAVE COMMITTED AND
I'LL SAY FOR A THIRD TIME THAT
WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
THROUGH CLARIFYING LEGISLATION
IN SOME FORM AND MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S NO AMBIGUITY- AND NO
DISCONNECT THERE. IN CENTER
DRAWS. IT WERE NOW IN- THE- AS
DRESS I KNOW ASKED FOR UP.
INTENT WE'RE NOT IN THE
CLOTHES. I WANNA BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SIXTY SECONDS. TO
REPRESENT OF THE BUILDING
TRADES ON THIS QUESTION IS WELL
AND THEN I WILL TURN BACK TO
CENTER DRAWS SO- AND THEN GO TO
THE MAJORITY LEADER. I MISS THE
HAND ON BEHALF OF THE BUILDING
TRADE SIXTY SECONDS PLEASE
CONSIDER DRESSES QUESTION
PEOPLE MIGHT- I JUST WISH THAT.
WE CAN MARK THE SECOND HERE. IF
YOU DON'T MIND GETTING CLOSER
TO THE MIKE I'M SO SORRY. THAT
IN THE MEDIA STATEN CAN WE JUST
DO A QUICK MIKE TEST. SHE SHE'S
ON OKAY PLEASE ASSIGN. WHEN
THIS BILL INITIALLY- CAME
FORWARD WE WERE AT WE VOICE
CONCERN WITH IT BECAUSE OF THE
STREAMLINING ASPECT AND WHAT
THAT WOULD DO- FOR LABOR
STANDARDS ON AFFORDABLE AND
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. IN THE
COASTAL JURISDICTION- IN THIS
BILL WAS THEN MADE INTO OVER AN
EXPANSIVE BILL STUDYING HOW THE
COASTAL COMMISSION. COULD
PARTICIPATE IN STREAMLINING THE
ANALYSIS ON THIS BILL ITSELF
RIGHT NOW SAYS IT CREATES A
CONFLICT I THINK THEY REFERRED
TO AN ANALYSIS. AS TO MASTERS.
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT EVEN A
PROCESS HERE BY WHICH THE
STREAMLINING WOOD WHAT HAPPENED
FROM COASTAL ON TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BUT WHAT WE KNOW
FOR SURE IS IN WHATEVER THIS
PROCESS IS. THE VOICES OF OUR
HALF A MILLION MEMBERS AND MANY
OF WHO LIVE WITHIN THE COASTAL
COMMISSION JURISDICTION WILL
NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
VOICE THEIR CONCERNS ON HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS AFFORDABLE AND
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
THAT OCCUR IN THEIR HOME TOWNS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WRESTLING.
TEAM IS THE MAIN WILL BE IF IT
WOULD HAVE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
SHOW- TAKE THAT UP ON BEHALF OF
THE BUILDING TRADES. A CENTER
DRIVE SO BEFORE WE TURN OVER TO
THE MAJORITY LEADER I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE
CONCLUDED YOUR REMARKS IN
MISTER MAJORITY LEADER BEFORE
WE GO TO YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM IS WELL. THE
CENTER DRAWS SO- PLEASE
PROCEED. WELL YOU KNOW MAYBE
I'LL LET THE MAJORITY LEADER
SPEAK TONIGHT. COME BACK WITH
OF COURSE YES MA'AM THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU MA'AM CENTER.
LAYS INJENICA MAYBE THAT TO BE
A RECEPTION QUORUM. MR NO CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MCGUIRE HERE MCGUIRE
PRESIDENT SENATOR NIELSEN.
SENATE PRESIDENT SENATOR
TORONTO TORONTO PRESENT SENATOR
HERTZBERG HERE HERTZBERG
PRESENT SENATOR WIENER WIENER
PRESIDENT DIFFICULT PARTISAN
SABAH SHOP FIVE MEMBERS ARE
PRESENT WE'RE NOT GOING TO TURN
THE FLOOR OVER TO MR MAJORITY
LEADER GOOD AFTERNOON SIR HE
WAS CHAIRMAN I WANT TO FOLLOW
UP ON SENATOR ASOS LINE OF
QUESTIONING BECAUSE- YOU KNOW I
THE SIMILAR CONCERNS. THE I HAD
A CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR
AND I GAVE MY WORD AND I TOLD
HIM MUCH SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND
I WAS HAPPY BECAUSE HE SAID HE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH THE
GERMAN. WORKING OUT THE DETAILS
BUT MY UNDERSTANDING FROM
TALKING AND INTO TIME TALKING
TO THE WORKING FOLKS OF THE
BUILDING TRADES THAT THEY THAT.
AND CONFIRM IT AGAIN HERE
TODAY. THAT THEIR CONCERNS WERE
BEING TAKEN CARE OF THE POINTS
THAT CENTER DROSTE SPECIFICALLY
MADE THAT ARE DEEPLY CONCERNING
TO ME. AND THEY TELL ME THAT'S
NOT THE CASE THAT THE
AMENDMENTS HAD CHALLENGES THAT-
WE'RE LAST MINUTE SO HEY JUST
RAISE THAT IN THE CONTEXT OF
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO HERE.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU WERE
GEORGE BUT I ALSO WAS BASED
UPON THE LEVEL OF
UNDERSTANDING. AND I WANT TO-
TO. HELP DEALING WITH YOU ON ON
THOSE ISSUES BECAUSE THEY'RE
PRETTY THEY'RE PRETTY IMPORTANT
MY JUDGMENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER INTERNALLY- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO AUTHORED TO RESPOND
PLEASE PLEASE AT SOME NUMBER
THE FOUR SOURCE THANK YOU
UNDERSERVED MAJORITY LEADER-
AND AGAIN I ALSO SURFACED
CONCERNS AND I THINK THAT THEY
ARE PRETTY DARN IMPORTANT AS
WELL TO- AND- AND LESS TIME-
YOU KNOW ABSOLUTELY FADING IN
MY MEMORY AT AGE FORTY FIVE. I
HAVE NOT HEARD THESE CONCERNS
UNTIL NINETY MINUTES PRIOR TO
THIS HEARING- AND PRACTICES NOT
ON RECORD AT THE LAST COMMITTEE
HEARING THAT WE HAD WHEN THE
BILL WAS- PRIOR TO ITS BEING OF
POLITICAL STUDY DOLLARS YOU
REMEMBER. I THANK HEARING WE
TOOK THOSE AMENDMENTS WHICH
THEN TRANSFORMED INTO A STUDY
BILL AS OF JULY THIRTEENTH
PRIOR TO THAT ALL THIS LANGUAGE
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY ONCE IN
PRINT. DID REALLY DIRECT THE
COASTAL COMMISSION TO ALIGN
SOME OF ITS STREAMLINING
PROVISIONS- WITH THE SAME KINDS
OF PROJECTS THAT ARE
STREAMLINED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE TELEVISION
QUESTION- TOWARD THE- BUT IF
SOMETHING WAS STUDY BY. COME
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE. THEN
IT'S STILL BILL IN ANYBODY
HEADED THE- DOESN'T CARE
BECAUSE IT'S STUDY BILL. AND IF
IT COMES BACK WITH PROVISIONS
DOESN'T THAT BRING BACK SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT. OTHERWISE
REYES TO ME. IF IT WAS A STUDY
BILL AND THEN COMES BACK NOW.
THE FINAL MONTH AND A HALF TWO
MONTHS LATER SO AND IN IN A
FORM THAT WAS SIMILAR TO WHAT
IT WAS. SEEMS TO ME THAT
CREATES SOME LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS NOW- SO AS WE HAD
WORKED WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND
WAS INTRODUCED TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE TIME- I BELIEVE.
MAYBE YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO BE
HERE FOR THE PRESENTATION
ALTHOUGH I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT ON IT- THERE WAS AN
OUTLINE OF WHAT WE WERE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO DO WITH THIS BILL
AND WE WERE VERY TRANSPARENT.%
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE MOVING
THIS FORWARD AND S. ANY.
STRONGLY AMENDED FORM TO STUDY
BILL. THAT IF WE WERE
SUCCESSFUL NEGOTIATIONS OVER
THE SUMMER RECESS WITH MANY OF
THE STAKEHOLDER AGENT GROUPS.
WHICH HAVE SINCE COME OFTEN
MOVED TO NEUTRALITY. THAT WE
WERE THEN GOING TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE THE FINAL FORM. BACK INTO
pITS- WHAT YOU SEE HERE TODAY
THROUGH THE SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE POINT TEN PROCESS. OKAY.
RICHARD ANY OTHER ITEMS YOU'D
LIKE TO ADDRESS AT THIS TIME.
YEAH IT JUST LAST QUESTION IS.
AS PART OF THE STAKEHOLDERS DID
YOU CIRCLE BACK WITH- LABOR ON
THIS BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT IT DIDN'T HAPPEN- AND
WHO IS INVOLVED. IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS IN ORDER TO COME UP
WITH WHAT'S BEFORE US TODAY.
ALTHOUGH I HAVE HAD A CHANCE TO
DISCUSS THIS BILL AS EARLY AS
MARCH OF THIS YEAR- WITH BOTH
THE STATE AND SOME OF MY LOCAL
TRADES MEMBERS. THEY HAVE NOT
EXPRESSED ANY INTEREST OR POINT
OF VIEW ON THIS BILL-TO MY
FACE. OKAY INTERLUDE OR
ANYTHING ELSE THANK YOU SO MUCH
I'M GONNA GO TO CENTER WINNER
THERE AND COME BACK TO CENTER
DRAWS OF PLEASE ENTER WIENER.
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S.
COMMITMENT TO- TO RESOLVING
THIS WITH CLEAN UP LEGISLATION
LAST YEAR WHETHER IT'S YOUR OWN
VEHICLE OR- OR A DIFFERENT
VEHICLE AND- AND OBVIOUSLY THE
HOME KEY ISSUE HAS. BE THE HOME
IS YOUR HAS TO BE OF SEX I PRE.
OKAY NOT A MINIMUM- WHAT I'LL
SAY ABOUT THIS BILL IS HOUSING
COMMITTEE. WE WERE THE THIRD
REFERRAL- AND ONLY THEY'RE ONLY
TO GOD THROUGH REFERRALS AND
NOT GET HEARINGS THIS YEAR- SO
THE AUTHOR- COULD HAVE DONE
WITH SOME OTHERS DO WHEN THAT
HAPPENS IS SORT OF TALKED. NOT
REALLY TAKE SERIOUSLY THE- THE
VIEWS OF THE THIRD COMMITTEE
AND IT JUST BECOMES A PARAGRAPH
IN A BILL ANALYSIS. BUT THE
AUTHOR TOOK OUR FEEDBACK ABOUT
VARIOUS ISSUES- VERY VERY
SERIOUSLY AND WORKED
INTENSIVELY WITH- SENATE
MCGUIRE IN THIS COMMITTEE WITH
OUR COMMITTEE- AND- KEPT HIS
WORD ON EVERYTHING HE COMMITTED
TO- AND BENT OVER BACKWARDS TO
RESOLVE THINGS AND IS DONE THE
SAME. WITH STAKEHOLDERS- IN A
VERY HARD BILL IN TERMS OF THE
BUILDING THAT POTENTIAL WAR
BETWEEN THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
AND THE COASTAL COMMISSION IN
CITIES IN THE COASTAL
COMMISSION- AND THE BILL HAS
BEEN. SCALED BACK ON QUITE A
BIT AND SO I'VE- GIVEN OF THE
AUTHOR AS HAVING METICULOUSLY
KEPT HIS WORD- OCTANT. TO ALL
THE COMMITTEES INVOLVED- I-
ABSOLUTE CONFIDENCE THAT HE'S
GOING TO DO. WHAT HE SAYS HE'S
GOING TO DO AND I KNOW. WILL.
MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS AND I
KNOW IT WILL HAPPEN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND CENTER WE'RE GONNA
GO CENTER DRESSER JEFF OTHER
ITEMS. SUCH AS A DOCTOR THANK A
QUESTION HERE IN TERMS OF- I
WOULD I REMEMBER BEING IN A
COMMITTEE HEARING THE WEEK OF
THE FINAL VOTE WITH SISTER A
COUPLE OF DAYS. BUT- IS THERE A
PROCESS WHEREBY. AND THIS IS A
VERY VERY HUGE ASSUMPTION.
ASSUMING THAT THE AUTHOR WOULD
AGREE TO THE CHANGES AS HE'S-
ASSISTANT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAYING TODAY THAT IT WOULD HE'S
COMMITTED TO MAKING CHANGES
THAT WOULD INCORPORATE OF THE
LABOR PROTECTIONS. OF CAN THAT
BE DONE. NOW MISS WHERE WE'RE
AT IN TERMS OF THE TIMING OF
THIS SESSION CAN THOSE CHANGES
BE MADE AND IT'S VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO BE TO MAKE THOSE
CHANGES AT THIS POINT- AND JUST
BEING CANDID NO LOOKS A
MAJORITY LEADER ON THAT AS
WELL- SO. LOOK I THINK THAT.
JUST BEING HONEST ABOUT THIS
AND JUST TALKING THIS OUT-
CENTER WINNERS RIGHT DID WITH
THE WHERE THIS BILL STARTED.
AND IN THE DISCUSSIONS THAT
WE'VE HAD- JOB OFFICER HAS COME
AN INCREDIBLY LONG WAY- IN
WE'VE HAD- VERY. OPEN AND BLUNT
DISCUSSIONS WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
COASTAL COMMISSION ABOUT SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES WITH THE
ORIGINAL BILL. AND I WANT TO
ALSO SAY THANK YOU TO THE COAST
COMMISSION- REPRESENTATIVES AS
FAR AS OUR STAFF AND TO THIS A
MEMBER FOR WORKING THROUGH.
pWINNER IS RIGHT HI THIS IS BEEN
A COMPLICATED ONE- AND TRYING
TO BE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH SOME
PRICKLY PEAR- THE ISSUES- IT IS
HOW WE GOT HERE TODAY.
REGARDING THE ISSUE- FOR
SENATOR I WAS IT WAS JUST
COVERING SO ELOQUENTLY IN
APPRECIATE AS AN ADDRESS THAT
WAS. NUMBER ONE. THERE IS GOING
TO HAVE TO BE CLEAN UP. YEAH
AND I. LOOK TO THE SENATOR
AFFIRM WHAT I'M SAYING HERE.
CLEAN UP EITHER THROUGH A
PERSONAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
IN JANUARY THAT WOULD BE FOCUS
ON ENSURING THAT ANY PROJECT
FROM KEYSIGHT- WOULD BE THAT
ABIDE BY THE SAME STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
IN LAW- AND OR THAT LANGUAGE
COULD BE PUT INTO- A POTENTIAL
BUDGET BILL FOCUS ON WHERE
PROJECT HUNKY IS WELL WHICH IS
BEEN DONE IN THE PAST. SO
THAT'S THAT'S ALSO BUT THE
AUTHOR HAS COMMITTED TO BE TO
DO PERSONALIZATION- ON THE
ISSUE PROJECT HUNKY NOW AGAIN
I'M NOT GONNA SPEAK FOR A GROUP
I KNOW THAT DOES NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH THOUGH FOR THE BUILDING
TRADES- AND AGAIN I DON'T WANT
TO SPEAK FOR THEM. AND WHERE
THEIR CONCERN IS THAT THEY'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE THOSE
SAME SKILLED AND TRAINED
PROTECTIONS IN REGARDS TO FOR
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN ON THE
100% AFFORDABLE IS WELL. THAT
THAT IS NOT IN FRONT OF US AS
FAR AS POTENTIAL CLEANUP I. THE
CLEAN UP RELATED TO- HUNKY IN
SKILLED ENTRY. SO THAT IS WHERE
WE'RE AT- HERE TO DAY AND THAT
WAS TO COME IN AND BY THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S WHILE THERE IS
A NUMBER AGAIN I DON'T WANT
TOWARDS YOUR MOUTH. AND I DON'T
MEAN TO KEEP COMING BACK TO YOU
BUT I DON'T WANT ANYBODY
COULDN'T. ANY WORDS IN MY MOUTH
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S ACCURATE SIR I APPRECIATE
THAT SENATOR ON IT WOULD BE
OKAY CANASTA LONGHOUSE MIGHT
LEAD WITNESS TO POSSIBLY ALSO
ADDRESSES ANOTHER EXCEPT NOT
AWFULLY INTEGRAL PARTNER AND
HOW WE MIGHT IMPLEMENT THIS IS
A CALL ON ZERO CHRISTY.
ABSOLUTELY SO- WE'RE GONNA BUT
SINCE WE'RE NOT IN THE CLOTHES
ARE GONNA BRING BACKS HERE
CHRISTIE- FROM THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. BUT MISS CHRISTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON I WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOUR WITH US. THANK YOU
SENATOR REQUIRED CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES SIR PLEASE PROCEED ON
US IN OUR DRAWS THIS QUESTION.
SURE I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF CLARIFICATION IF
THAT IS HELPFUL- FIRST OF ALL
THE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE-
CURRENT REQUIREMENTS. THE
PROJECT HOME HERE WHEN HE
THOUGHT ARE GOING TO CHANGE IN
WITH THIS BILL ALL THIS BILL IS
GOING TO DO IS REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THURMOND TERREL C.
P.'S TO SPECIFY THE LOCATIONS
AND THE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
THOSE PROJECTS WILL TELL
NOTHING NOTHING'S GOING TO ANY
ANY REQUIREMENTS THAT ALREADY
ATTEND THOSE PROJECTS FROM
EXISTING LOT WILL STILL CARRY
OVER IT'S JUST GOING TO BE.
THAT THERE WILL BE AFFIRMATIVE
STATEMENTS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
CLARITY IN THE L. C. P. ABOUT
THOSE PROJECTS BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE MOST PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNDERTAKING PROJECTS IN THE
COASTAL TOWN WHAT. THE FIND OUT
WHERE THE RULES ARE. SO I. THE
OTHER THING I'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT IS THAT THERE'S NOT GOING
TO BE A SINGLE ADDITIONAL
PROJECT IT'S GOING TO COME TO
THE COASTAL COMMISSION BECAUSE
OF THIS BILL. THAT WOULDN'T
ALREADY COME TO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. THIS IS ABOUT AGAIN
AMENDING THE LOCAL PLANS.
HOUSING HI. SO IT'S THE
SENSUALLY JUST A BILL TO
PROVIDE MORE CLARITY IT'S NOT
GOING TO CHANGE. ANY OF THE
EXISTING REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS AROUND THOSE BELTS
I HOPE I HOPE THAT THAT IS
HELPFUL. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS
CHRISTY ON THE QUESTION CENTER
AS A POLICE. WELL I'M YOU KNOW.
MR THE FIRST TIME WILL BE A YOU
KNOW SORT OF IN THE MIDDLE OF
TWO TWO SIDES THAT WE AGREE I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE YOUR INTENTION TO. BUILD
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON THE
COAST AND YOU AS YOU SAID I WAS
ON THE COASTAL COMMISSION I
KNOW THE OF. DEBATES IN BATTLES
THAT WE HAD ON THERE ON A LOT
OF THINGS RELATED TO. YOUR
WORKING PEOPLE. OF BUT IT'S
JUST IF THIS IS THE LAST.
OPPORTUNITY TO DO ANYTHING I
REALLY DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
AND NOT HAVING THE LABOR
STANDARDS. UP IN THE IN THE
BILL AND- A- YOU KNOW. IT IT
JUST SEEMS ESPECIALLY IF IT'S
NOT APPLICABLE TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. READ THAT MR AT PLEASE
I WANT TO SEE THOUGH IT HAS
SOME REWARD POINTS TO REACT AND.
TESTING OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE UNDER LAW TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE ARE PROVIDED
FOR ANY SUBJECT PROJECT
PRODUCTS THAT THAT WILL NOT
CHANGE. THIS IS REALLY JUST TO
MAKE SURE THIS ADDITIVE LAYER
THAT WE HAVE ON THE COASTAL
CAMELON AT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION'S. REVIEW IS ON THE
STREAMLINING ISN'T MIRRORED.
RELATIVE TO THE PERMITTING THAT
WE SEE UNDER A LOCAL TOURIST
PROCESS THESE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER MAJORITY LEADER
PLEASE. I JUST WANT REPEAT
WOODS CENTER DRAWS AND I'M
UNCOMFORTABLE OF LABOR
STANDARDS IN A DIFFICULT
POSITION BECAUSE I TOLD YOU MY
WORK AND I HAVE NEVER BROKEN MY
WORD EVEN WHEN I MADE A
MISTAKE. I WANTED TO. RICE OF
THIS BUSINESS. YOU TELL
SOMEBODY IT'S MY OBLIGATION I
WAS IN THE OPPRESSION THAT IT
WAS TAKEN CARE OF. I HAD TALKED
TO THE LABOR FOLKS WHO TOLD ME
THAT IT WAS TAKEN CARE OF
BECAUSE NO ONE KNEW THAT. WE
WERE GOING TO GO FROM A STUDY
BILL AND FRIDAY NIGHT TILL NOW.
SO I'M UNCOMFORTABLE BUT I'M
GONNA VOTE FOR THIS TODAY
BECAUSE I TOLD YOU I WORK. BUT
I'M TELLING YOU THAT I MAKE NO
COMMITMENTS AND TO DO SOME MORE
HOMEWORK THAT I WILL VOTE FOR
THIS ON THE FLOOR. BUT I WILL
NEVER BREAK MY WORD AND I MADE
A MISTAKE BECAUSE SOMETHING GOT
SCREWED UP IN THE PROCESS. AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE NOTION
OF LABOR STANDARDS I DO THINK
THAT THIS IS A DIFFERENT ISSUE
THAN HOME KEY. PERSONALLY
APPLICATION OF THESE LABOR
STANDARDS MORE BROADLY
SPEAKING. WHICH CREATED SOME
PROBLEM AND WHERE WE ARE TODAY
SO I JUST YOU KNOW IT IT IT IS
WHAT IT IS. IN THE FAST AND
FURIOUS OF THE WORLD WHICH WERE
IN THE LAST DAYS OF SESSIONS
HARD CERTAINLY HAVING A OFF THE
FLOOR HEARING LIKE THIS IS
CHALLENGING. BUT I WILL NEVER
BREAK MY WORD I GAVE IT TO YOU
I WILL VOTE TODAY. BUT I BETTER
BECAUSE OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I CAN'T TELL%
YOU A LITTLE FROM THE FLORIDA
KEYS AND WALLMARK. BECAUSE I
WAS THE IMPRESSION THAT THAT
ISSUE WAS TAKEN. CARE OF. AND
OF COURSE IS THAT- IT IS A NEW.
ISSUE FOR ME AT THE MOMENT I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
PARTIES THEY HAVE THROUGHOUT
THIS PROCESS. OF IN MANY VOICES
THAT AWAIT INTO THIS AND- IF
IT'S- OKAY WITH THE CHAIR AND
I'D BE HAPPY TO. POSSIBLY CLOSE.
THIS IS DRESS I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT DID YOU HAVE ANY
OUTSIDE BEFORE WE CLOSE OUR
DRAWS A DEEP. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. PLEASE SOME REWARD. WE I
THINK IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING
YOU ALL KNOW WELL WE HAVE NO
SHORTAGE OF ISSUES TO WORK ON
YEARS OF HOUSING BUT
PARTICULARLY ON SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE ON.
RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITIES WITHIN
THE COASTAL ZONE. MANY OF WHOM
HAVE BEEN ASKING ME AS WELL TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE EXTENDING
SOME F THOSE VERY SAME
STREAMLINING PROTECTIONS. THAT
ARE ALREADY AFFORDED- FROM THE
FOR PROFIT TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
BUT ALSO. TO BE ABLE TO HELP
THEM GET THROUGH THIS BECAUSE
WHAT SOMETIMES CAN DO WITH THAT
TIME TIME IS MONEY. FROM
DEVELOPMENT MAY NOT EVEN WANT
TO BE ABLE TO. ENTERTAIN IS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW. WHAT WOULD
BE A GOOD INTENDING AND WELL
INTEGRATED PROJECT INTO A
COMMUNITY TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING A WORKFORCE HOUSING. IS
JUST NOT GOING TO ACTUALLY
PENCIL OUT OF THE WRIST THERE
WOULD BE TOO GREAT. THAT WAS
THE ORIGIN OF THIS BILL. AND SO
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF. EQUALLY IMPORTANT
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO IT THAT WE WOULD.
SATISFYING AS WE TRY TO BE ABLE
TO SOLVE. MANY OF THE
CHALLENGES AND- STATUTES AND
ON. AND SUPPORT FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CALIFORNIA WE WILL DO
THAT AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT TOGETHER AND SO MY
COMMITMENT REMAINS TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT- THROUGH. THE
PURPOSE AND THE OUTCOMES OF
THIS BILL. IN ALL THE
LEGISLATION THAT I WILL BE
WORKING ON IN THE AREA OF
HOUSING. PRODUCTION GOING
FORWARD AS WELL SO- WITH THAT I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
HERE TODAY- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IDOL AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE- SPECIAL.
ATTENTION AND PROVISIONS THAT
YOU OF AFFORDED. TO BE ABLE TO-
CONTINUE TO GUIDE THIS BILL TO
WHERE IT IS HERE TODAY AT THIS
LATE HOUR. THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
THE NUMBER THAT SYSTEM MEMBERS
CLOSER MOTION TO APPROVE PLEASE
ON THE FLOOR MOTION TO APPROVE.
WITH EMOTION MY CENTER WIENER-
MR. CANAL CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS THAT
THE MAY. B. WERE. TO SENATE FOR
CONSIDERING. SENATOR MCGUIRE
HIGH STREET- A SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN KNOWS SENATOR DORADO.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. RIGHT
HERTZBERG HIS SENATOR WIENER
WIENER HI THAT IS A S. THREE
ONE VOTE THREE ONE VOTE THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS A MEMBER THANK YOU TO ALL OF
OUR TESTIMONY LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THAT IS GOING TO
CONCLUDE OUR SEPTEMBER SEVENTH
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE MEETING THANK YOU SO
MUCH LISTEN GENERAL. LITERATURE.